mais presque personne ne dira qu'une plante, un arbre
ou un arbuste ont un cerveau.
Et quand on pousse l'idée
- parce qu'on pourrait en fait décrire un peu
le vrai fonctionnement du cerveau ainsi -
on insiste :
« Pourquoi les choses vivantes en ont un et les autres choses non ? »
Souvent ils répondent en disant
que les choses qui bougent ont un cerveau.
C'est tout à fait vrai.
Notre système nerveux a évolué car il est électrique.
Il est rapide afin de pouvoir répondre aux stimuli de ce monde
et bouger s'il le faut.
Mais on peut revenir et pousser un élève plus loin,
et lui dire : « Tu dis que les plantes n'ont pas de cerveau,
mais elle bougent. »
Quiconque a fait pousser une plante
a remarqué que la plante bouge
et se tourne vers le soleil.
Mais il va dire, « Mais elle bouge lentement.
Ça ne compte pas. C'est peut-être un processus chimique. »
Et pour les plantes qui bougent de manière rapide ?
En 1760, Arthur Dobbs, gouverneur de la Caroline du Nord,
a fait une découverte assez fascinante.
Dans les marais derrière sa maison,
il a découvert une plante qui se fermait
chaque fois qu'un insecte tombait dedans.
Il a baptisé cette plante l'attrape-mouche,
et en 10 ans, elle a réussi à se déplacer jusqu'en Europe,
où Charles Darwin a pu l'étudier aussi,
et cette plante l'a tout bonnement fasciné.
Pour lui, c'était la plante la plus merveilleuse du monde.
Cette plante était un merveille de l'évolution.
Cette plante se déplace rapidement,
elle est rare,
et tout aussi rare, elle est carnivore.
C'est une seule et même plante.
Je suis ici pour vous dire
que le plus extraordinaire avec cette plante,
c'est qu'elle sait compter.
Afin de le démontrer,
il faut d'abord passer par un peu de terminologie.
Je vais faire ce que je fais avec mes élèves.
On va faire une expérience en électrophysiologie,
l’enregistrement du signal électrique du corps,
que ce soient ceux des neurones ou ceux des muscles.
Je pose des électrodes sur mes poignets.
Quand je les connecte, on va voir un signal ici sur l'écran.
Et ce signal peut sembler familier.
On l'appelle ECG, ou électrocardiogramme.
Il vient des neurones dans mon cœur
qui déchargent ce qu'on appelle des potentiels d'action,
le potentiel étant le voltage et l'action car il monte et descend vite,
ce qui fait marcher mon cœur,
ce qui provoque le signal qu'on voit ici.
Alors je veux que vous reteniez la forme de ce qu'on voit ici,
car elle va jouer un rôle important.
C'est une façon dont le cerveau encode les informations
dans un potentiel d'action.
Observons maintenant quelques plantes.
D'abord le Mimosa pudica,
on trouve cette plante en Amérique centrale et du Sud,
et il a des comportements particuliers.
Voici le premier comportement :
si je touche les feuilles ici,
vous voyez qu'elles se recroquevillent.
Le deuxième comportement,
si je touche la feuille,
toute la branche semble tomber.
Pourquoi ?
La science ne sait pas pourquoi.
Une raison est peut-être de faire fuir les insectes
ou de sembler moins attrayant pour les herbivores.
Comment fait-il ? Ça, c'est intéressant.
Faisons une expérience pour savoir pourquoi.
Ce que nous allons faire,
comme quand j'ai enregistré le potentiel électrique de mon corps,
on va enregistrer le potentiel électrique de la plante, du mimosa.
J'ai enroulé un fil autour de la tige
et où ai-je mis l'électrode de terre ?
Dans la terre. C'est une blague d'ingénieur. D'accord.
(Rires)
Bon. Je vais toucher la feuille ici,
il faut regarder l'enregistrement électrique
qui se trouve à l'intérieur de la plante.
Oh, c'est si énorme que je dois le diminuer.
Bon. Alors, c'est quoi ?
C'est un potentiel d'action qui se déroule dans la plante.
Pourquoi a-t-il eu lieu ?
Elle voulait bouger, non ?
Alors quand j'ai appuyé sur les récepteurs du toucher,
un voltage a été envoyé à travers la tige
la faisant bouger.
Dans nos bras, ça ferait bouger les muscles,
mais la plante n'a pas de muscles.
La plante a de l'eau dans ses cellules
et quand le voltage la touche, elle s'ouvre et libère de l'eau,
la forme des cellules change, et la feuille tombe.
OK. Voilà un potentiel d'action qui encode de l'information de mouvement.
Peut-il faire plus ?
Allons voir.
Regardons notre vieille amie, la dionée attrape-mouche,
regardons à l'intérieur, que se passe-t-il dans la feuille
quand une mouche atterrit ici. ?
Je fais semblant d'être une mouche.
Voici ma dionée attrape-mouche,
et à l'intérieur de la feuille, on va voir trois petits poils,
ce sont des poils déclencheurs.
Quand une mouche atterrit --
Je vais toucher un poil.
Prêts ? Un, deux, trois.
Que se passe-t-il ? Un beau potentiel d'action.
Mais le piège à mouche ne se ferme pas.
Afin de comprendre pourquoi,
nous devons en savoir plus sur le comportement de l'attrape-mouche.
Primo, ça prend du temps pour ouvrir le piège --
environ 24 à 48 heures s'il n'y a pas de mouche à l'intérieur.
Ça nécessite beaucoup d'énergie.
Deuxio, elle n'a pas besoin de manger beaucoup de mouches par an.
Quelques-unes. Son énergie vient surtout du soleil.
Elle remplace quelques nutriments de la terre par des mouches.
Tertio,
elle n'ouvre et referme le piège que quelques fois
jusqu'à la mort du piège.
Alors, elle veut être convaincue
qu'il y a un repas à l'intérieur avant que le piège ne se referme.
Alors, comment ?
Elle compte le nombre de secondes
entre les touchers successifs des poils.
Donc la probabilité est forte
que si une mouche se trouve à l'intérieur, elle se fermera ;
au moment du premier potentiel d'action,
elle commence à compter ;
si elle arrive à 20 et ne décharge pas à nouveau,
elle ne se fermera pas,
mais dans le cas contraire, le piège se ferme.
Revenons en arrière.
Retouchons la dionée attrape-mouche.
J'ai parlé pendant plus que 20 secondes.
On voit ce qui se passe quand je touche le poil à nouveau.
Que se passe-t-il ? Encore un potentiel d'action,
mais la feuille ne se ferme pas.
Alors si je retourne là-dedans
et je suis une mouche qui vole,
je vais toucher la feuille quelques fois.
Je vais la frôler quelques fois.
Immédiatement,
le piège se ferme.
On voit que l'attrape-mouche fait un calcul.
Elle calcule si une mouche se trouve à l'intérieur,
et puis elle se ferme.
Reprenons la première question.
Est-ce que les plantes ont un cerveau ?
La réponse est non.
Il n'y a pas de cerveau.
pas d'axones, de neurones,
Elle ne déprime pas.
Elle ne veut pas savoir le score des Tigers,
ne connaît pas de problème d'épanouissement.
Mais elle a quelque chose de très semblable à ce que nous possédons,
la capacité de communiquer avec l'électricité.
Elle utilisent d'autres ions que nous,
mais fait la même chose que nous.
Afin de vous montrer
la nature omniprésente des potentiels d'action,
nous l'avons vu dans la dionée attrape-mouche,
on l'a vu chez le mimosa.
On l'a vu chez l'être humain.
Voici l'euro du cerveau.
C'est le chemin que prend l'information.
On peut utiliser ces potentiels d'action
pour faire passer l'information
entre les espèces de plantes.
Voici notre communicateur entre les plantes d'espèces différentes,
nous avons crée une expérience tout à fait nouvelle
qui permet d'enregistrer le potentiel d'action de la dionée attrape-mouche,
et on va l'envoyer au mimosa.
Rappelez-vous ce qui se passe
quand on touche une feuille de mimosa.
Il a des récepteurs qui envoient de l'information
vers le bas sous forme de potentiel d'action.
Que se passe-t-il
quand on prend le potentiel d'action de l'attrape-mouche
et on l'envoie dans les tiges du mimosa ?
On devrait pouvoir recréer le comportement d'un mimosa
sans le toucher.
Alors, si vous le permettez,
je vais activer ce mimosa
en touchant les poils de la dionée attrape-mouche.
On va envoyer de l'information sur le toucher d'une plante à l'autre.
Et voilà.
Alors --
(Applaudissements)
J'espère que vous avez appris quelque chose sur les plantes,
mais aussi qu'on peut se servir des plantes
pour aider à enseigner les neurosciences.
et amener la neurorévolution.
Merci.
( Applaudissements )